joining me now is Nathan sales former
Ambassador at large and counter Terror
coordinator under Trump and Christian
Whitten who's a former Trump State
Department senior adviser senior fellow
at the center for the national interest
Christian uh let's start with you I mean
the media are really trying to sell this
as some you
know Reagan rikic moment with gorbachov
I mean I don't think that flies but
could there be some residual benefit for
Joe Biden after the dust settles on the
summit no I don't think so I mean if you
go back to the reason he won in 2000 is
because he was kept out of the public
Spotlight uh the more people see him the
more people see his cognitive decline
the more people see that he looks like a
junior partner to xiin Ping and really
just came out of this Summit with
nothing I mean we have this fake
agreement on fentel I'll believe that
when I see it I don't think the Chinese
are going to change their conduct at all
and we also agreed to to limit the use
of artificial intelligence and Military
applications that hurts us that hurts
the United States that's an area where
we could actually get an edge on China
uh and get ahead of their very large
military buildup but he gave this away
and got very little got really nothing
in
return now Nathan The Economist is out
with a delusional piece today that was
titled Donald Trump poses the big danger
to the world in 2024 they're arguing
that the greatest threat Mr Trump poses
to his own country and China and its
friends would Rejoice over the evidence
that American
democracy is
dysfunctional Nathan here you have
trillions of dollars in corporate wealth
gathered to prostrate themselves at the
feet of a communist dictator and The
Economist is saying Trump's the problem
Trump's
anti-democratic I mean Laura it's
deranged
um look around the world the world is on
fire Russia has invaded Ukraine in a war
of aggression that seems to me to be a
pretty big threat to the United States
in the world order China is hungrily
eyeing Taiwan across the straight xiin
ping is going to use military force if
he can he's told the people's Liberation
Army be ready by 2027 and this is what
the economist is worried about what
about Iran uh which just launched a huge
war on Israel using its Terror proxy M
um and is launching I think over 60
rocket attacks through its proxies on
American forces across the Middle East
that where's that in the conversation I
think you know the The Economist has
just lost its mind if it looks at the
world and thinks that the United States
is the major problem
here well Christian the interesting
thing in this manma survey again it just
came out is that foreign policy is way
down on the list of concerns um
including you know Ukraine and there's
some more concern for Hamas but not much
it's still our border our economy um
crime is even actually fairly low in
this new survey which I found
interesting but it's really the economy
and the Border are the dominant issues
which again ex I think explains Trump's
enduring appeal in a state like New
Hampshire that's kind of a quirky state
for Republicans um but Trump's up I
think uh almost what 40 points over
Nikki Haley right I think for right well
for foreign policy being low I think
part of that is explained by the
Washington Mono Party Trump and DeSantis
have differed from the status quo from
The Establishment on Ukraine but you
still have both parties in Congress
itching to spend billions more now the
new speaker of the house is separated
Aid to Israel from Aid to Ukraine but uh
guaranteed by the end of December
certainly by the end of January these
people will have sent billions more of
our dollars to a stalemate in Ukraine uh
after a counter offensive that has
failed so you know foreign policy really
hasn't been on the agenda and I think
won't be until Trump or disantis put it
there but economically yeah I mean no
matter how much they tout by nomics
people understand that they have lost
25% of their purchasing power all 25% of
your savings uh 25% of your ability to
buy something whether it's a house or a
hamburger has been taken away by Joe
Biden permanently that's what the
problem unless we go to deflation that's
not coming
back well I think even the New York
Times had to admit that that Biden's
biggest enemy out there it's not it's
not the anti-democracy forces in the
United States it's the lowered buying
power of Americans because of sustained
inflationary uh pressures uh Jennifer
palmary um Obama's communications
director had some amazing advice Nathan
for how Joe Biden can really run and run
strong next year watch you could run on
the American Military being the
strongest in the world American
leadership being restored the American
economy rebal ing from Co and democracy
while constantly under threat more
people are voting and President Biden
can do this it's not just
biomics Nathan did Biden succeed on
anything that you just mentioned
there I it seems like she's grading on a
curve Laura um look the the no nobody
nobody can look at America's position in
the world today and say that we're
better off today than we were 3 and a
half four years ago
um Vladimir Putin was not deterred uh by
the Biden Administration he launched a
war of aggression in Ukraine and then
the Biden administration's response to
this has been to Slow Roll Aid um rather
than giving Ukraine what it needs to win
the Administration has given Ukraine
just barely enough to stay in the fight
and prolong this for for for months and
months and months longer than necessary
when it comes
toon it's awful lot of money Nathan you
and I could debate Ukraine for for an
hours here but suffice it to say that
$120 billion from what we were saying we
were getting that's just I mean the
American people are going to just say no
to that I'm sorry that's just American
people have already said no to that but
um we obviously know who the good guys
are Christian whiten and Nathan thit
sales thank you so much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else